attendez là je lui raconterai une icône
qui c'est qui va lui prendre le terrain
un clochard très connu un clochard vrai
même tunique au super énervés frère il
est parti en bons chez lui grosse batte
de baseball ils n'arrivent pas papa papa
clochard lula parfois tu veux quoi il
tâtera par lequel ferait il que tire sa
grand-mère et dollars tepa frère et moi
j'avais peur est un boxeur le clochard
frère je crois les boxeurs j'ai entendu
je suis pas sûre et attend c'est pas
fini il fera ce n'est pas fini mais non
satan l'intense eryasa frères syriens
frère il te pose sur la chaise
il commence à l'entour étant tour de
scott je sais pas comment ils
l'entourent et sa mère c'est pas fini il
va chercher l'eau bouillante
les browns 5 elle ferait ravi de ma mère
puyo puyo au huitième degré sens mais il
a tellement crié sa grand mère on aurait
gianni 15z qui passe en bas vers dans le
quartier beaucoup trop cher il à
montigny clip ici là maintenant lui
personne parlait lui seul patron là il a
monté une équipe il est lui la vieille
la vieille l'actif une du site la barre
junior au dégoût face faire marche
arrière ce faire google
on découvre pas chez moi c'était plein
on va discuter toits de lauzes gier toi
tu vois moi je trouve pas des mois la
mythomanie ici chez moi c'est contagieux
trois au caire trois stades et plan
basket foot c'est à des plans passe à -0
6 secondes je ne peux pas ce qu'on veut
on change de banque mais la manne
bombay
vous
je
petit
et
les vacances tu te lèves tu t'habitues
en garde à vue oui je suis con
l'ambiance non bien c'est quand on
marque 45 degrés tout le mettre en garde
à vue tu te lèves tu t'habilles on
t'embarque tu restes tu t'assois et on
boit un verre et sans l'air de
plaisanter d'y attiser l'église poser
les armes
ici on est chez moi n'y a pas de danger
mettez vous à l'aise ici à rien vous
allez retrouver et tu vas me dire que ça
avec ton rsa que tu te payes cette
baraque
j'ai gagné au loto et la loto ils
resteront encore 100 kilos là bas voilà
tu vois comme ça mais ça c'est du
chocolat c'est du chocolat a battu
remerciera nico pour le chocolat nico
et proto lé vrai ton histoire est aussi
vrai que tu à te tais pas c'est un
charmant it or mépris du quartier
regarde ça on peut en faire des pièces
des maraudes je jouais quand on a une
des pièces t'inquiète
toujours dans ce squat
tu seras tranquille lors personne ne le
calcul est vraiment jusqu'au jour où
allure à moi je me souvenais pas je vais
bosser
viendra tout train toujours prof quoi
kevin qui compte sur toi pour les cours
de mac comme sur moi c'était comme à
cannes est court il a dit qu il devient
quoi il tient toujours l'europe et où
nico c'était le poivron du quartier
attend bel âge le rat confrères trois
ans j'ai que ça il faudrait d'abord
qu'ils n'ont plus rien ni quand je dis
aux mots plus réussi et qui va lui
prendre le terrain un clochard frère
laurent barthez jusqu'au sur mon terrain
je crois que c'est comme dans la vie on
parle avec mon amie on faisait une
petite bavette quoi à force de mettre
des claques ont fini par s'en prendre
une bonne est le fruit du hasard
moi je suis comme ambiance tu te lèves
tu t'habilles on t'embarque je reste tu
t'assois et ont bon averti puis à 4 ans
et toutes ses dents mon tennis et
piscine et lui
cassez vous dit si mamie rose prenantes
cette idée qu'il a fait et malawi contre
elle est bloqué on dirait l'a vu eva
mendes la vieille là qui fume du shit la
barre génial
c'est quoi la zle je me fasse comme
verront change de bans mais la mano